es ist ein historisches datum heute in
england wissen sie der letzte arbeitstag
von theresa may als chefin der
konservativen partei die mary poppins
der tories fliegt davon wenn ich das mal
ein bisschen poetisch sagen darf bei und
so absurd es klingt meine damen und
herren man wird diese frau noch
vermissen denn ohne sie spricht leider
vieles für den ganz ganz harten
drechselt da fehlen wird uns frau aber
natürlich vor allem als tänzerin hier
nochmal auf vielfachen wunsch der tanz
zum wechsel katrina
das duo chicago
ja
rhythmusgefühl ja vorhanden
stimmig
mir persönlich tut theresa may
tatsächlich leid
sie müssen sich vorstellen als wäre
seine letzte woche im abend nicht
traurig und schlimm genug kriegt sie in
der woche auch noch besuch von donald
trump dem großen brett fan diesen
hooligans gewesen klar ist der für den
exit das für alles was der eu schadet
und weil die engländer dringend ein
freihandelsabkommen mit den usa brauchen
wirklich dringend musste sich sogar
neuer family prostituieren
trump ist nach bush und obama erst der
dritte us präsident dem die volle ehrung
als staatsgast zu teilte seine familie
hat er einfach mitgebracht
da gibt es sogar vier seiner fünf
branchen hatte einfach mitgebracht
ja schlimmer als besucher aus der zone
das war wirklich was für ein alptraum
vor allem für die arme alte queen ja
allerdings
allerdings durften die asis aus amerika
die tramps im gegensatz zu früheren
präsidenten nicht im buckingham palace
übernachten man hat trump gesagt kein
witz da würden zufällig gerade alle 52
gäste zimmer renoviert
irgendwas muss ich mehr sagen
also wie gesagt ich hab heute handwerker
da immerhin hat er trump ein
staatsbankett gekriegt er soll man nicht
meckern
und wenn man sich dieses foto anguckt
denkt man erst ja der smoking sitzt
suboptimal aber tatsächlich hat er wohl
für den langen abend in den innentaschen
nur ein paar dutzend cheeseburger
versteckt und das trägt halt auf ist
klar
zur enttäuschung vor allem auch der
deutschen medien fete bei diesem besuch
allerdings der ganz große klar weil
trumps leute ihn gut vorbereitet haben
hier das original briefing für trump da
stand dann zum beispiel so die heißt
queen ganz wichtig doppelt nicht
anfassen da nicht da schon gar nicht
überall nicht das sind william und harry
beide sind nicht deine söhne viel zu gut
aussehen das ist mir genagt und das
angela merkel klingt ihnen sind aber
zwei verschiedene frauen schreibt das
auf das hier nennt man these sondern hat
kaffee für vollversager und das
wichtigste wenn dieser oper dich mit
seinem auto irgendwo hinfahren will lauf
weg donauried
was man was man so hört trump selber war
super zufrieden mit seinem besuch in
england
wer sich tatsächlich in einem einzigen
foto wunderbar zusammenfassen lässt in
diesem einen wunderbar überlegen sie mal
mich dieser hybrid schrammt sich
ungefragt in die bresche debatte ein die
gegen ihn noch gar nichts an und das bei
einem new deal irland wieder eine harte
grenze kriegt die man unbedingt
verhindern muss hat trump obwohl man es
ihnen wirklich mehrfach erklärt hat
immer noch nicht so richtig verstanden
hier treffen mit dem irischen premier
eine grenze oder mauer gerade vermeiden
bauer wollen wir hier nicht mehr wenn
kollegen mit der reden wie mit einem
kind das gerade von der förderschule
geflogen ist dann hast du ein problem so
wie geht es weiter mit trump mit england
mit der groko mit allen das verrät ihnen
schon jetzt unser sommer orakel dietmar
wischmeyer
acht leute allem an eincremen so wird
der sommer im juli schlägt donald trump
sein militärs vor endlich mit dem
dritten weltkrieg loszulegen dafür
sollen im ersten zehn millionen iraner
und ein automechaniker dran glauben
wieso der automechaniker fragt dann
general ich wusste es sagt tramm keine
sau interessiert sich für zehn millionen
iraner scherz beiseite das thema das
noch heißen sommers 2009 10 bleibt
natürlich der klimawandel die
afrikanische riesen zeckenbiss aus
westfalen vorgedrungen und verfolgt die
menschen bis in die wohnungen kreises
for future plagen gehen freiwillig
wieder zur schule weil es draußen zu
heiß ist selbst die afb ist auf dem
klima zug aufgesprungen und fordert die
rückkehr zur durchschnittstemperatur von
1936 die spd erfreut sich weiter
sinkender beliebtheit
the floor is the limit noch im august
machen die verzweifelten so ziehen als
erste partei der welt ein kevin zum chef
um das gesamte gesellschaftliche
spektrum abzudecken heißen seine
stellvertreter mandy murat und adolf
zugehen volkspartei hat die spd zu wenig
bewerber für den spitzenkandidaten
sollte cdu eine zu viel
die gretel aus püttlingen sowas würde
einem nicht mal die spd als kanzler
material anbieten
doch es kommt der tag da will die säge
sägen und zwar im stuhl der saarland
krampe allein wer unter den geistigen
warmen duschen der union hat den mumm
für ein attentat auf das leid tun
vielleicht jens spahn
der kleine streber hat weiter ein gesetz
nach dem anderen raus organspende
erhalten künftigen baumärkten 20 prozent
rabatt auf alles und
wirklich revolutionäre auch auf die
nahrung verweigert sind automatisch
spender und gelten als bundesorganen
reserve doch spannend umstrittenes
projekt ist der gesetzesentwurf zur
sterbehilfe
danach ist schluss für einfacher
mehrheit unter den nächsten angehörigen
und dann im herbst wird es emotional
deutschland verabschiedet sich für immer
von der sommerzeit ab dann gilt
ganzjährig die deutsche bahn zeit immer
zirka 40 minuten später als die uhr
zeigt bleibt als letztes noch zu
erwähnen dass auch diesen sommer wieder
zig millionen deutsche eine fernreise
antreten und jeder einzelne davon an
ökologischen fußabdruck hinterlässt wer
ein kompletter indischer bundesstaat
das wirklich schlimme aber ist sie
kommen alle wieder zurück die heute show
allerdings auch bis september
nicht der offizielle
und wenn sie zu hause meine damen und
herren tatsächlich nur so lange wach
geblieben sind weil sie auf ein
interview mit markus söder warten dann
war das leider verschwendete lebenszeit
denn lehrt uns abgesagt wegen aktueller
termine vielleicht irgendwas mit einer
sterbenden groko vielleicht muss auch
noch bis 2020 den grünen motor
entwickeln keine ahnung
so oder so das war die letzte heute show
vor der sommerpause unsere online
redaktion arbeitet aber durch das
internet kennt keinen urlaub unter
anderem gibt es frische youtube beiträge
jeden freitag jetzt kommt aspekte wir
sehen uns wieder am 6 september bis
dahin schon so manches
guten tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des
heute show youtube kanals begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort